hello and welcome to the home of the
Oscars the Dolby theatre hearin cold and
wet Hollywood the red carpet tented
right now to help us escape the rain
fortunately the forecast for Sunday is
mostly sunny skies so right now the
biggest concern is avoiding another Best
Picture debacle and I spoke to host
Jimmy Kimmel about a rumor due over for
last year's presenters Ron what did you
do warm baby will he come back
[Laughter]
we'll have to ask him that question
there's a mistake
moonlight you guys won Best Picture
after the biggest blunder in Oscar
history a source tells ET that Warren
Beatty and Faye Dunaway are expected to
get a second chance and will present
Best Picture at the Oscars on Sunday
you'll call Beatty was handed the wrong
envelope last year the epic mess-up has
become a great promotional tool what do
I do
I don't care what you do just get out of
my house so what do you know now that
you didn't understand before I didn't
know that there were two envelopes I
figured there was one well actually
there will still be two envelopes one
for each side of the stage but the
Academy has announced new safeguards to
make sure something like that doesn't
happen again including special
rehearsals staff changes and a member of
the accounting firm will now be in the
control room
the other big story heading into the
Oscars is Ryan Seacrest it's so exciting
that it's Oscar weekend an E
spokesperson tells us Ryan will be on
the carpet
despite sexual harassment claims by his
former stylist Seacrest vehemently
denies the allegations he was in LA this
morning hard at work at one of his other
hosting gigs we are on the set of
American Idol today as for the Oscars a
source tells et that some Hollywood
publicists are considering having their
clients skip interviews with him on
Sunday and there is a report that his
producers will pre arrange his
interviews to avoid the scandal coming
up on live TV
[Music]